i'm
sarah graffeny palermo on twitter i'm
super sgp
so if you like the opinions you hear
here today
there's way more of them on the internet
so up until very recently i was an
engineer
at kickstarter i left about a month ago
to have a career
crisis and find myself but that's what i
used to do
when i'm not coding for money i'm
actually coding for art i do live code
as well
those svgs i make with clojurescript
uh handmade artisanal svgs in brooklyn
and i'm really excited to be here today
to talk to you guys about errors
and i have a lot to say i realized by
the way when i was writing this talk
that it's actually
like four talks and rather than make it
shorter i just decided i was going to
talk really fast
so if some of the slides go by fast you
don't read the code
don't worry it's going to be on the
internet there's lots of links
with like details so you can see it all
later
so let's get started lately i've become
super interested
in the way that we approach errors as
programmers
as a culture and i wasn't going to start
off telling you why i got interested
because i feel like it's a little bit
incendiary but i decided i'm just going
to go ahead and tell you now
and hope that you'll keep listening even
if you think i'm kind of insane
but i'm interested in errors because i
really hate
types um and i know that that's not like
a really popular opinion here in 2018
right this idea that i as someone who
only knows
some programming think that like i know
way better than all these computer
scientists who have done research and
have told us that types are like the way
to do it right
um but i know that type errors are real
and so i was like well if i wasn't going
to be into these
how am i going to have a better way to
approach errors so i decided to do some
research
and luckily errors are really
interesting on the one hand
they're this cursed object that explodes
rockets
overdoses people on radiation and makes
web forms refuse to submit when you need
them the most
and as such there are danger around at
which every right-thinking person is
furiously erecting fences right
but on the other hand errors are kind of
hilarious
so consider the case of nuclear gandhi
um
in the very first civilization game for
some reason towards the end of the game
gandhi would suddenly become incredibly
aggressive and start threatening to nuke
everyone which if you know gandhi is
kind of unlike him right
um so it turned out that aggressiveness
was represented with an unsigned bite
and when gandhi's was set to one and the
player took an action like adopting
democracy
that made it drop even further it
flipped around to 255
and gave gandhi max aggression players
liked this error so much that sieve
still uses it even though the mechanism
has obviously been discovered and
understood
errors can also make us inventive so in
wing commander
the game threw an error when you
completed an out of memory error
and the programmers could not figure out
why it was throwing this error but
you know sometimes you just got a ship
so they changed the error message to a
message of congratulations and just went
on with their day
errors can also be delightful so when i
was working on my live code framework
doing some animations i forgot that
rotations needed to be stateful from
frame to frame
so i accidentally made this shaky circle
friend um
because it restarts the animation every
50 milliseconds
um but it's one of the most popular
effects people love it when i use it in
shows they're always like that circle so
cool
so you know and then i broke that once
and made this other really cool rotation
that fixed the thing i broke i don't
know i thought they were both pretty
cool
to our credit as programmers we
recognize that errors are an inevitable
part of our culture
right we've all identified with this dog
sometimes we feel this way about css
you know we resent those movie
astrophysicists who can save the ship
while we get a bunch of nands
we have complicated relationships with
code
and we all know our own call of the wild
and so errors can be terrible and they
can be hilarious and they can be amazing
and maybe if they're terrible we should
just cool it and not worry about what
we're missing out on
but you know something i noticed is that
examples of interesting errors
come from things like games and art and
bad errors come from things like
healthcare and
rockets but fortunately as web
programmers we're much closer to the
former
even though as a culture we tend to act
as though we're the latter
and we really think beyond how to fix
errors
and it's not really a big surprise
actually so
culturally and philosophically we're
trained to deny and avoid error in
pretty much every aspect of our lives
as catherine schultz tells us in her
book being wrong
which by the way is a book when people
see you reading it they all want to talk
to you
this view is really common and it's very
popular with a number of heavy hitters
in history
plato thomas aquinas um and it
comes from the idea that errors are a
product of a gap
between the true world and our flawed
human minds as we attempt to interpret
it and this is kind of the view that
gives us a yearning for
correctness
however there's also an optimistic view
of airing
and in this more modern view originating
in the enlightenment
the idea is that this gap is the result
of imperfect perception but it can be
faced and overcome
as we asymptotically move towards truth
in fact seeing the world perfectly as it
is might not even be the right goal
as schultz writes seeing the world as it
is not is pretty much the definition of
airing
but it's also the essence of invention
imagination and hope
this gap may also just be the downside
to our massively great inductive
reasoning upsides all the shortcuts we
take that make humans
such good thinkers inventors planters
some like
intuitive little plants right all of
this means that sometimes we misperceive
so maybe we can risk it up um so i'm
going to talk
a little bit more today about what we
mean by errors
how we deal in javascript now situate
that historically
and then go ahead and see what other
options might be available to us in the
future
so what do we mean by errors there's a
lot of different schemes that people
have come up to answer this question
a lot of the times they split along the
lines of whether
it's an avoidable programmer error or an
unavoidable universe failure
sort of like we see here from the first
edition of eloquent javascript
i think that's not the most helpful way
to look at it because if we've seen if
errors are inevitable to us as humans
then that's
just as much a universe failure as
anything else so the framework i like
comes from slips mistakes and failures
from thomas petrachek
and this is by sort of the magnitude so
slips
are where your idea was right and you
tried to encode it the right way but
you made a syntax error or a typo and i
always think of these as areas that we
don't really ship
because they break right away the linter
catches them
at the other end of the generality
spectrum we have mistakes
where you made an error thinking through
the specification
and that's really fuzzy like what does
specification even mean
but i just think of a mistake as
building the wrong thing
in the middle we have failures which is
where you had the right idea but encoded
some part of it poorly
and this is what we're most concerned
with day to day
so how does how do we deal with these
failure type errors in javascript
um javascript uses a type of exception
handling that's about
half the original system used in pl1 in
1968.
there's pl1 up there in the language
family tree descending from fortran and
algol
in javascript exception handling arrived
in es3
and worked pretty much as it still does
today right
we have the error prototype to construct
errors
we have the keyword we have the throw
keyword to propagate them
we have try catch and finally to create
a new lexical environment to handle the
exceptions
and then to clean up after their mess
whatever can't be fixed by resetting the
lexical environment you can use finally
to clean up
one thing that surprised me in my
research is there used to be a
non-standard multi-catch syntax so
instead of having to put a conditional
inside your catch
you could just do catch catch catch
catch
but that's not been there since firefox
59 so that vote kind of sailed
in addition to user-defined errors there
are six built-in error types
only five of them are still thrown eval
error just exists for backwards
compatibility
the biggest change to error handling in
the spec arrived in es5 with early
errors
which is mostly used for strict mode to
be sure the heap is not littered with
landmines which is to say there's no
code in memory that's not going to
execute
and to disallow code that would
otherwise be allowed by the grammar
but these are reported when the program
is evaluated not when it's run
so it's not part of our exception
handling scheme um
inside the exception handling system
things are pretty much as they are in
most other languages
but in this case common is definitely
not a synonym for optimal
when the invoking function is able to
use catch to respond to an error
the stack trace is available but the
invoking function cannot affect code
anywhere down the stack from itself
so consider this example um there's this
parse entry function
which throws an exception when it can't
parse a file and it's getting called
four file four functions in two lines
deep you know
maybe it's inside a library and this
analyze all files is in your code
when it fails and throws we might as
programmers actually have
an idea say of a good default we could
use to continue
so the parsing could keep going and we
don't have to unwind the loops
and maybe if only we had a default right
we could rewrite the function
to like account for the fact that you
could return a default value
but i think you can see how making this
the responsibility of this inner
function
both breaks encapsulation and like could
quickly get out of hand if you had ideas
for other sorts of interventions
and so we might be able to do something
but it doesn't matter because it's not
possible without pre-processing the data
or rerunning the entire function
other changes to exception handling have
come obviously in javascript with
promises and the sync await
these haven't changed the basic concept
though they've extended it
they've made for some interesting corner
cases and variations
for instance if you return from a nested
finally
you're never going to call your outside
handler so we'll never print banana
which is very tragic
um errors may also remain entirely
uncaught by a chained catch
i didn't realize this until i was
messing around but that first promise
isn't going to be caught by the catch
um there's a probe there's a proposal
for promise.tri
that would address this but currently
that's a big sticking point
then with the sync await the variations
in pitfalls increase further as my
friend francis found out
he had a fun bug where using this
function log stats was being called
twice
and then throwing an error he wasn't
sure why it turned out that an external
function used by log stats was throwing
and being caught which surprised him
because he was just thinking of that for
the await
so he came up with some solutions
you could just only wrap the await in a
try block which is what a lot of people
have done
if you have a lot of async it leads to a
ton of trying obviously
you can use the goify pattern where
basically
you create a promise that returns an
error data tuple
so then you're handling errors on a per
promise basis
or you could change the catch but as we
discussed before this won't actually
catch if the promise throws
so there's a lot of variations with
implicit pattern trade-offs but at the
base it's the same try catch mechanism
finally it's also worth noting before i
go on that the dom
does provide error event listeners which
look really interesting
i've never seen them used in production
and i didn't even know about them so if
anyone out there is actually using this
please come talk to me because i'm
really curious how you're doing it
so basically this is javascript's fairly
unexceptional
exception system um it has some funny
little corners and on the one hand
it's super unremarkable and yet it seems
strange that such a remarkable language
built to be so dynamic for all of the
good and ill that that implies
and bounds strongly to its earliest
choices through its commitments not to
break the web
should have what amounts to a kind of
anemic way of dealing with errors
and it's this lack of balance that i
suspect sometimes leads to javascript's
reputation as a problem child or a foot
gun
and lately the answer to that has been
to dial down the dynamism
but as i've mentioned before i'm not
super into that solution
so i've written and spoken about this a
little bit before if you're interested
later you know dm me
but the short version of the argument is
that
the choice to pour our limited
engineering effort into a totalized
static typing system for javascript
both in tooling and in day-to-day
product engineering is a mistake
type checking only catches type errors
and there will always be points of
failure in an application
that deals with networking user input
and the dom
one of my proudest type based
achievements is i've actually thrown a
runtime error in elm which people claim
is impossible but
it turns out when you're pending strings
to the dom no one can really save you
um also though maybe being saved isn't
so great
um maybe being so correct forces us to
create
huge unwieldy systems and being small
and composable
makes your programs easier to understand
even if slightly more error prone
maybe working with computers in a tight
iterative loop is just more pleasurable
and maybe looking at computers as
conversation partners
instead of as half cop half servant is
better for us
as human beings and these are all good
reasons to give error handling a second
look
and there's also i think a political and
aesthetic reason
to move away from solution through
specification
the idea that the best way to be safe
is to make being unsafe illegal has deep
roots in computer sciences positive is
history
but this approach blocks out the strange
the hybrid the human
it prevents us from discovering weird
mistakes like shaky shapes
politically it also harms us by
insisting that only strong categories
are valid and denying liminal spaces
which is to say complex truths
right consider the us census um up until
i was 20
it was only you were only allowed to
pick one race because that's what the
system could handle but that's not true
i am not one race like that's not the
answer um
and it took more work and the acceptance
of looser categories for the system to
even reflect some portion of that truth
the same can be said for gender identity
right there's not two answers there's
not four
so the idea that we should restrict
ourselves to communicating in a way that
machines can understand instead of like
working to make them partners seems to
me like the path to a pretty barren
future so i'm going to tell you about
errors in history right and see
where we really came from
if we arrange general error handling
methods from the dramatic to the subtle
in this list comes from chris hauser
exception handling comes right in the
middle
at the top the most dramatic option is
to just crash
this is obviously the original classic
direct from fortran
um and it makes sense when a computer is
a glorified calculator and you have a
knowledgeable operator sitting right
there
right why keep doing calculations if
they're going to be wrong crash and fix
it
um but in modern times this can be
anywhere from inconvenient to
really terrible um so for instance
recently
the new york city subway replaced some
signals including a computerized signal
and it turned out that the switch had a
bug and the only way to work
on it or to fix it was to reboot the
subway
which took a really long time and was
incredibly inconvenient
so in this case just crashing was
probably not the best idea
between just crashing and throwing an
exception is the idea to enter a
debugger which you might be familiar
with if you've used rails very much
right on a rails dev environment if you
throw a bug you can enter the debugger
and those switch engineers maybe would
have appreciated this approach to
rebooting the train
less dramatically you can return a
special value this approach
is pretty uncommon in modern languages
except for some utility functions right
find index will return negative one um
and callbacks where errors passed is the
first value this approach suffers from
the semi-predicate problem
which is to say that you have to check
for it explicitly that's its biggest
downfall
um even more deprecated as an approach
and one of the first solutions after
just crashing is to set an error flag
this was common in things like basic
um and i think you can see how like
setting an error flag would lead to
returning a value would lead to throwing
an
exception you know even further outside
to help the system deal with it
and then finally we have the least
dramatic option which is to recover and
keep going
and sometimes this seems a little
ridiculous why hide errors
only terrible things will happen and
they will be so hard to debug
but context and possibilities for
recovery really matter here
this is what html does for instance
right like maybe you didn't close a tag
but you can still read the text
and even though it can seem impractical
there are times it's the most practical
so i learned from wikipedia when i was
working on this that the default
ieee 754 floating point exception
handling behavior
is to resume computation following the
substitute of a default value
if you have an arithmetic error and this
actually would have prevented the 1996
ariani 5 explosion
which was caused in part by the fact
that ada just aborted computation
on an arithmetic error like an integer
overflow
finally we can add a few other elements
to the list of ways to
we've historically dealt with errors you
can send a signal which is a little bit
different from a return value because
anyone can listen from it
for it but you're not throwing it
and there's option types and maybes
which could possibly fall under keep
going
um some approaches can be seen as a
combination so erlang is basically
signal plus crash plus recover
um and that's sort of where we are but
let's look at where we could go this is
the last section
um there's a lot of different routes we
could take to expand our approaches to
errors and adjust our relationships to
machines
and as i think about where i want to see
computing go in the future
i keep coming back to this tweet from
emilia mcnamara about a talk brad myers
gave a dog stool
contrasting you know traditional
programming language goals correctness
performance to new ones like
modifiability and learnability
in particular i always think of errors
or a better
error handling method as involving these
last two modifiability and learnability
to get there we might focus on things
like more robust ways of dealing with
nullability as it exists
today and that's coming right there's
the optional chaining proposal that i
think is in stage one
that would you know by reducing the
number of checks for small quotidian
errors free us up to focus on exception
handling
and that might pair with you know
expanding ways to work with errors as
events
or focusing on good default arguments
focusing on defaults leads us into a
more broad look
at rigor at robustness in addition to
rigor which is to say
looking for things that will bend and
not break
that makes recovery more possible and
less disruptive
this might look like augmenting or
rebuilding the current exception system
remember when i mentioned that
javascript's accession system is only
half a system compared to pl one
so as described in the canonical
exceptions paper from 1971
exceptions and exception handling
mechanisms are not needed just to deal
with errors
they're needed in general as a way of
conveniently interleaving actions
belonging to different levels of
abstraction
they're not necessarily rarely activated
and so this
involves moving you know responsibility
up the stack but not necessarily
unwinding errors which is to say context
is maintained
it proposes a specification for
exceptions that have three types
escape signal and notify which can
require termination
be the caller's choice or forbid
termination
and it's these capabilities that were
hacked off from c
plus do the determination back in 1989
that since no one really used them in
cedar mesa
nobody should ever have them in their
exception handling system ever again
basically
if we wanted to leave the past in the
past a focus on robustness could be a
focus on maintaining
good state in the face of user
interaction um
for instance i use fig wheel for live
code when i make an
error it actually just keeps the last
good state going while telling me that
i've created an
error um react's error boundaries
also do the same thing and if you can
imagine sort of combining this
insistence on maintaining good state
with the ability to access a production
rebel
right we could do all sorts of crazy
good live fixes that wouldn't hurt users
um what would continuous deployment be
like if you deployed an error you
identified it in the repo
you made a hot fix in one restartable
module right like
that could be a really amazing way to go
back and forth with your system when you
define
errors then if we got really crazy we
could look at stealing good ideas from
even further a field
one is recovery blocks so this is a
pattern where you
create an acceptance test you give a
list of ways to attempt a successful
result
and then if all of this if all of those
fail
then you know then the error is thrown
and
this the acceptance test usually can
access
variables from you know before and after
the functions are run
so that works for pre and post
conditions or domain and range errors
another option would be to look at
algebraic effects and handlers
implemented in things like f this
handles errors in a monadic style
if you're not familiar with ocamel
syntax this might not make a ton of
sense but
the really important part here is that k
which is the continuation so you can
intervene and then pick up where the
language left off
lexically finally we could just head for
the stratosphere and consider ways to
reframe our relationships with computers
but you could make computers a full
partner with program slicing and better
automatic suggestions
the rosette language extends racket to
use
solvers and synthesize code we could
also take the alternate approach
and work to reframe computers from
something that just works
to something that may be tinkered with
and grown and might not be just this
machine for brutal effectiveness
um and some of these seem really big um
and really fast and very undetailed
but it's only by wanting more that we're
going to get explorations into getting
more
but there is something we can do today
and that's to make it culturally
acceptable
even encouraged to spend time thinking
about ways to fail well
instead of just trying not to fail
altogether
and so in terms of encouragement i have
one last quote from you
again from being wrong we want to turn
away from error
because it reminds us of our existential
despair that we're separate
from truth and from one another
but also the only true way to engage
and to create and imagine is to risk
error
so i let's let's not cut ourselves off
at the knees
by underestimating ourselves and our
machines maybe
let's not be afraid instead let's make
it safe
to take some risks and throw some errors
and then to continue thank you guys so
[Applause]
[Music]
much
well